let's talk about specs what is a spec
what is a spec a special purpose
acquisition company
which to simplify what a spec is it's
essentially going public
without having to spend the four to 10
million bucks of going public and
waiting 18 months to go public it's
somebody that already has a holding
company on the market
with some cash in it and the stocks
around 10 some of them are 10
and 50 cents because they got a warrant
on a back end and you go and say hey
let's do something with the spec
couple months later you're on the market
with a ticker okay so that's a spec to
simplify but
let me read a few things here for you
roger lee of battery venture says that
spak used to be a bad four-letter award
in silicon valley now the board of every
high-profile startup is discussing
spec as a legitimate way to go public
according to jeff crowe of norwest
venture pardon the sudden burst of spax
reminds some long-timers of the dot-com
bubble in the late 1990s pre-revenue
businesses with far out goals are going
public at astronomical valuations and
famous athletes and other celebrities
are getting in the mix
the wall street skeptics it looks like
the finance industry's latest scheme to
make money
speculators etc etc right 44 billion
dollars so far in 144 deals
according to a spec insider but the
following names have gone into the spac
movement shemat who's a potential
governor in california
serena williams steph curry shaq alex
rodriguez billy bean tillman frittata
billy fo
there is a lot kaepernick just got it
there's a lot of people that are going
into the spot market and silicon valley
saying
maybe this is the way to go because
people don't want to wait that long
thoughts on specs let me tell you
something i
quite candidly never heard of a spack
until like the last one for a while i
thought it was a super political action
committee
you know you have a pack i thought it
was a spa oh you got it back
that's true because they do call it
super pac but i don't know if it's just
because i've been you know following
chamath's interviews a little bit more
lately and he's quote unquote the king
of the spak
but it's starting to pop up more and
i've currently here i've heard it and
you know i'm
covering a little bit on the finance
stuff and valuetainment economics and
and finally yesterday i was like pat we
were kind of brainstorming ideas i'm
like
what's up with all these spac talk not
smack talk
not you know now we're doing here and
you're like you were like intrigued you
were almost like thrown off like well
what do you know about us back what do
you
what's so into what you were just like
who told you about spec
it's just been popping up a lot more
lately so give the
the audience what they want give them
that spac talk to them
what's the point here you just have to
keep in mind spec is you
saving time and money from going public
that's what a special competition to an
ipo yeah
different speed to market just think
about speed
to market if it if a regular if you ride
on the run a company you're doing 50
million a year 100 million or 200
millionaires whatever you're doing
and say guys i want to go public okay
good for you
lawyers galore accountants
ridiculous going through a goldman or
somebody that's gonna say we're gonna
take a five percent fee or ten percent
fee or six they're gonna take that as
well because when they take you public
they're calling their clients so they're
taking a fee
for helping you raise capital and take
12 to 18 months versus somebody comes
and says look i'm already public
why don't you put your company in my
spac and then at the same time i can
help you be public in the next
you know 30 to 90 days so it's speed to
market
but what doesn't happen is the following
what where spec doesn't work is the
following
there are a lot of spacks that get a bad
reputation because there is no company
it's not a company it's an idea so there
is no
proof of revenues there's no proof it's
just here's the idea that we have and
here's what we're going to do and let's
go on the market and we think this idea
is going to blow up and be a
multi-billion dollar company
and the market's like but what do you
have so far when then
when the market comes in and does the
investigation like dude these guys have
nothing going
on those are the spacks that take about
and there's a lot of spacks that people
are going out without a real business
you have to be very careful of that but
traditionally you got a real business
you're doing well for yourself you got a
transportation company guys doing 120
million a year you're netting 10 15
million dollars you're like okay
let's go take a look at being a spec
yeah you've got a real business going on
interesting are they bringing in the big
name athletes just for the name factor
and recruiting factor and just uh
credibility is that why you're seeing
these guys
you got to realize back so so spax so
imagine you go out in a spec and you're
a half a billion auto company the guy
that owns the spec
currently the holding company that guy
ends up taking somewhere between you
know 15 to 20 percent of shares so if
you got 15
to help you go public that's essentially
the cost it would have been anyways if
you waited 18 to 20 you know fees and
everything yeah
so he takes 15 so you go public they say
okay we'll let your company be part of
our spec
half a billion dollars the hopes is a
year later for that company to be worth
what
you know uh a billion dollars if it's
worth a billion dollars
that guy officially doubled his 100
million to 200 million made a hundred
million dollars okay then he liquidates
50
of that then he liquidates 25 of that et
cetera et cetera so there's a lot of
opportunities and by the way for some
people like
i don't want to put my money into spec
most people that go into spec a company
that goes on a spec the ceo the guy at
the top the executives cannot sell their
shares
they have to stay on so it's not like
hey i'm in got the money i'm out there's
a timeline
because they're watching you so
regulators are watching you so
yes it's actually a very uh interesting
thing that's creating it's been around
for a long time
but today a lot of people since things
are moving quickly
are very much interested in specs and
some of the terminology you hear
always thrown around with spac you
always hear blank check
companies why are these why is it
considered a blank
check company because there's no there's
no company in it it's just money it's a
holding company with money in it
it's a whole new shell company it's a
shell that you just plug in
all right yes we're gonna do that's a
good way of putting it okay yes
it's a shell company so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye